Aristotle wraps up nikka McCain ethics
book five which is all about justice by
asking an interesting question and then
giving his views on it he asks is it
possible to do injustice to oneself to
be unjust to oneself and you know
there's there's multiple senses of
justice as you can see in the other core
concept videos that we've got on this
topic so you can think of all those
different types you know is it possible
to be unjust to oneself in the sense of
how you distribute benefits to yourself
and to others is it possible in terms of
reciprocity is it possible in terms of
the you know complete virtue or you know
complete vice is it possible in terms of
legal justice and Aristotle you know he
actually treats this as a real live
issue because people did in fact discuss
this and debate this whether one could
treat oneself unjustly or be unjust to
oneself and so there's this reflexivity
there it's not like being unjust as
somebody else or being unjust within my
society it's rather somehow doing
something wrong to myself that goes
beyond harming myself it's certainly
possible for me to harm myself the
question is that injustice it's
certainly possible for me to damage my
own interest it's certainly possible for
me to you know place myself in
conditions of ignorance the question is
am i doing something unjust thereby so
Aristotle says no and he has two main
sets of considerations one is short and
one is long with a number of different
sub points the first part he says well
look you know one sense of justice is
legal justice following the law and the
law forbids
thing so you know for example with anger
the law forbids me when I get angry at
somebody just walk up to and cold [ __ ]
them and you know say haha there you go
you got me angry you had it coming so
that that's assault you know or or
something else it might be you know put
down raised up could be attempted murder
you know depending on what's going on
exactly the law also says stuff about
what you're allowed to do to yourself
out of anger here's where Aristotle is a
really interesting example he talks
about people harming themselves or even
killing themselves because of their
anger and if we you know if we look at
Greek tragedies we see instances of
people doing things like this out of
anger out of shame this was a big open
question for the Greeks Aristotle
actually goes so far as to make an
argument here saying look the law
doesn't say that it's okay to do it so
in this case it's not okay to do it a
little strange reasoning on his part
because it's a little uncharacteristic
of him but Aristotle thinks that is
wrong to to kill yourself but it's
really interesting to see why he thinks
is wrong are you you're certainly
harming yourself if you kill yourself
and I stand herself with a knife because
you're so you're so upset are you doing
injustice to yourself aerosol says no he
says who are you actually behaving
unjustly towards and being an ancient
ancient Greek he you know his answer is
you're doing you're doing harm to the
state I think that for us moderns we
would have less of a conception of that
but you know the first for some people
they might say um you know my church my
club my classmates they're going to be
very upset
I do this there I'm going to be
depriving them of me my company i'm
going to be harming them in some way
that's wrong something that i shouldn't
do those who have children you know
should I should I kill myself well you
know then I'm leaving my children
without a father or without a mother
brothers and sisters you know parents
you know sometimes people actually do in
fact harm themselves so they can stick
it to somebody else and Aristotle I
think would be willing to go beyond just
talking about the state and say that by
doing this harm to yourself you are
being unjust to somebody else you know
another example that we do have is if
you're in the military and you you know
shoot your foot off because you you
don't want to be in combat you can get
in trouble for that because you're
you're you're you know officially
something that belongs to to the army or
Marines or Air Force I think of our me
because I was a soldier myself so in all
of these cases one is not able to be
unjust towards oneself it is possible
further to be unjustice in it for one to
be unjust but it's in relation to those
who would be harmed and lawned by one
harming oneself same thing to go for you
know crashing your car because you're
you're you know upset or something along
those lines well the car is needed to
take your kids to school or to purchase
groceries and cart them home or you know
any one of a number of different things
then you would be acting unjustly in
relation to those who are going to need
that the car so eres little line of
reasoning there makes quite a bit of
sense the only thing that he says is if
we're thinking about injustice in itself
and we're not thinking about other forms
vicious behavior or behavior that's a
long the line of vice and so a little
bit of you know review before we do this
Aristotle thinks that it's possible to
have a vice a bad defect within oneself
as a character flaw that's become
established within one's own soul or
personality that's bad that's going to
lead you to sort of automatically do the
wrong thing and actually see the wrong
thing is the right thing and the desire
to do the wrong thing it's also possible
without being vicious to do the sorts of
things that vicious people do to commit
a act for example you know cut the
coward characteristically behaves in a
cowardly manner because they have the
vice of cowardice it's possible for a
person to behave in a cowardly manner to
do a cowardly act at one given time so
that's part of what we're talking about
here Aristotle is trying to distinguish
between all these other vices like lack
of self-control with respect to food
with respect to sex with respect to
taking it easy whether you know how one
uses one's resources and either being
generous you're being stingy or being
being a prodigal with it how one seeks
out honor or respect or positions or you
know prestige that sort of thing these
are all ways in which we can be good or
we can be bad justice putting all these
over here justice has to do with you
know well or honor or position or these
sorts of things where we can have more
or less of it where the just is what's
in between and if you have too much
that's that's not fair that's being
taken from somebody else if you have too
little that's not fair either somebody
else is getting over on on you so
Aristotle is asking is it possible to be
only unjust not the ad in these other
ways towards oneself because it's
certainly possible to be in temperate or
in moderate with with how one manages
food with respect to oneself is it
possible to be unjust in relation to
oneself yes for considerations were
saying no one is look as he has to do
with adding and subtracting and so you
can't be giving yourself too much and at
the same time giving yourself too little
of the same thing gets the unjust people
if I'm unjust to you in a relationship
maybe I monopolize the time in the
conversation and it's always about my
stuff and my stories and you feel
deprived you feel that's not fair right
I am being unjust exile taking something
from you i'm adding it to me and i'm
subtracting it from you now if it's me
who is the person who's both adding and
subtracting at the same time does that
really make sense it doesn't work out
because there's you know you don't even
have like a circulation right it's the
same person doing the same thing so that
doesn't work that's that's a decent
point right there he also says something
has similar look injustice if it's
really injustice is voluntary it's done
by choice pro i racist in greek meaning
it's part of one's one's character one's
fabric of reasoning and desires it
involves acting if i do injustice i do
injustice i act if i undergo or suffer
or experience injustice that is a
passivity and so it's not possible for
the same person to be active and passive
in the same respect with themselves
Aristotle would say that one you know
maybe maybe that depends on our
metaphysics of the human person
um Aristotle also doesn't think that
it's possible for us to be treated
unjustly and for it to be voluntary in
the sense that we're okay with it we say
yeah I understand exactly what's going
to happen I understand that it's wrong
that it's unfair to me that I am going
to lose something in this process that I
shouldn't lose but I'm okay with that I
choose that as opposed to this other
thing over there now thats that's one
more probably some people would say no
it is possible to do that that's you
know what self-sacrificing is or you
know you know there's a lot of examples
that we could bring up but Aristotle
things that doesn't make sense for a
person dude it's not really voluntary
when they they do that so if one can't
have other people committing injustice
against oneself and it be voluntary on
one's part then it can't really work for
oneself I can't be committing an
injustice against myself and it'd be a
case where I'm voluntarily suffering
injustice from myself who's voluntarily
doing it to me that one takes a little
bit of thinking his last consideration
there's certain cancers certain
injustice is certain ways of being on
just certain ways of taking more than
once fair share that you can't commit
against yourself by the very nature of
the act and what it entails this is a
really brilliant point I have to say can
you commit adultery against yourself you
can commit adultery right against your
spouse go and sleep with somebody else
or you know you seduce somebody else's
spouse that's adultery as well the
Greeks were in on most ancient people
saw adults
is a really big problem you know not
just you know it is a matter of
sexuality in general but once you're
married there's supposed to be certain
restrictions but can you commit adultery
against yourself it doesn't seem like it
could who are you going to cheat with
how are you going to cheat where you are
the one who's being who is doing the
cheating and being cheated at the same
time that doesn't seem to to work same
thing with theft you know if this is my
piece of chalk you know I can certainly
do all right now the left hand to get
the right hands wondering where it is
but I know where it is because I'm the
the same person you can't actually steal
from yourself I mean you can set up a
corporation that's your corporation and
you know take more than your fair share
from it then we call that embezzling
right that's that's not only in action
against yourself but against other
people and you get in trouble for it
because other people get get upset about
breaking and entering you can't break
and enter into your own house you
certainly can like knock the door down
yeah kayaks or a ram and bash it in you
could have a storage locker and you know
get a sludgy and we're knocking the lock
off or you don't snip it or you know cut
it with a hacksaw or something like that
but you're not committing injustice of
that sort against yourself because it's
your stuff so we could think of a lot of
different different types of behavior
like this you can't defraud yourself you
know so aerosol would say that's you
know at least with those types of in
justices those particular acts of
injustice you can't possibly be unjust
towards yourself so the culmination of
all of this is that no you can't in fact
be unjust towards yourself you can't do
in just
to yourself he does hold out one way in
which this could work but requires you
to think of the human being as not being
a unity if we think of the human being
and in terms of the parts of the human
being and we could do this with you know
a faculty psychology where we have said
reason and the desires or you know the
better part of ourselves and the worst
part of ourselves or we can think about
you know our organs or you know we can
even think you know right hand left hand
if we wanted to in that sense
metaphorically it is possible for one
part to get more than its fair share of
something at the expense of another part
and since both of those parts belong to
the person one part of the person is
being unjust to another part of the
person so the person is kind of being
unjust to him or herself but this is
Aristotle says this is a metaphorical
extended analogical sense it's not in
the strict sense and it requires us to
do some some you know imagination in
order for that to to really work so you
know the long and short of it is it is
not possible according to Aristotle for
a person to be unjust to themselves